is on the wings of
one two three key looseness mom and dad
what's going on here what years at our
family gathering you to show up and you
ruined it I want you to bring a date to
your sister's wedding we don't want you
showing up stag and Ryland each other up
will shape up Eugenie you gotta find the
right girls for this where do we even go
what we're about to do something awesome
I'm here with Mike and Dave Stengel they
are looking for dates for their sister's
wedding in Hawaii let's make these guys
take us away we're looking for nice
girls we're gonna look respectable as
part of the plan
are you okay I am now save your life
grandma meet Alice she's super smart
Gianna she's a school teacher
the key to teaching children is is
repetition you'd be surprised how stupid
they are we take it easy absolutely not
we should let them lose with dignity
which is what I'd like to think we would
do like you guys are like watching porn
our they have the rod father I don't
know if we're gonna get it though if we
haven't seen the Godfather III make you
look cool
don't ever do that do anything that they
could do
looks like let me get to Barbie and
they're black Jen look I think not
affection here's a thousand clever